so I wanted Donna somewhat to sing the
song
I wanted Barbra Streisand the right to
lyric Barbra was doing
Yentl Donna was working everywhere
United Artists wanted me to think about
this girl who had done a song called
morning train which was a little pop
thing right and I thought that Shirley
Bassey and the tradition of bond or the
Trisha Devon was Shirley Bassey not
necessarily Carly Simon not necessarily
McCartney but I thought the girl is
saying morning train is impossible to
sing a bond picture sheena comes over
and has a wonderful range she can sing
low she can sing high and I says well if
I don't I have to demonstrate that in
the song so I says well alright I can't
get the lyricist I want pick a lyricist
that you like she picked her friend Mick
Lisa okay he writes a song that goes on
for three minutes and ends for your eyes
only
wonderful I have a meeting with cubby
broccoli after a lunch with maurice
bender the title designer have you
noticed how much maurice likes nude
women
but a charming man a vertically
challenged man a wonderful man I'm
having lunch with Maurice before having
an audition of a song that I've written
with Mick Leeson that after three
minutes ends for your eyes only
I think it's pretty good Maurice is
lamenting he says ah I can remember when
the title of the song and the title of
the picture would come on at the same
time Thunderball Goldfinger in here I
get something that after about an hour
and a half says for your eyes only so he
convinces me hour after this meal I'm
going I'm getting like I call off the
meeting with cubby I said I'm so sick at
the end of this lunch I can't make the
meeting I go back to Mick Leeson I said
forgive me listen you this song begins
for your eyes only
I don't care what you say after that so
it's not really how you're supposed to
do it but that's how we did so when mr.
bender vertically challenged Maurice
meets shorter Sheena you know when a
cartoon when you see those things going
above his head I watched this bed go oh
my god he fell in love immediately with
Sheena and then that's why she ended up
in the